wir halten fest politiker ist mehr denn
je ein höllenjob wirklich einen
höllenjob auch weil immer noch wichtige
daten zu corinna fehlen
wie viele menschen sind wirklich schon
infiziert wann kommt die große studie zu
antikörpern die berater der
nationalakademie leopoldina sind für
lockerungen haben sie gelesen
die kollegen vom helmholtz zentrum eher
dagegen was machst du da als politiker
und wir medien sind derweil ja nur noch
verliebt in unsere virologen oder jaja
achten sie mal darauf manche
journalisten sind team drosten andere
eindeutig team kekulé wieder andere
lieben den herrn streik ja weil er so
positiv klingt und die berichterstattung
wird wirklich immer spezieller an diesen
drei virologen wird aktuell in
deutschland kein weg vorbei christian
drosten ist der virologe der stunde
corona aufklärer wird er genannt und dr
corona genau bekannt aus dem film james
bond jagt dr groner komisch dass
christian drosten so unglücklich ist mit
seiner darstellung in den medien ich
verstehe das gar nicht in der sz war
neulich von sein und die zieht ihre
sinnlichen lippen die rede
ja wahrscheinlich folgt bald der erste
arzt roman doktor corona abstrich aus
leidenschaft oder so die virologen
selber das ist wichtig die virologen
selber sagen entscheiden müssen am ende
politiker
sie liefern wissenschaftliche expertise
von stand heute und dann kann die
politik ihre schlüsse ziehen aus so was
hier solche infektionswelle ist so etwas
wie eine naturkatastrophe in zeitlupe
und da kann man nicht sagen wie es
weitergehen wird
ich höre da immer so ein satz der heißt
eine pandemie ist eine katastrophe in
zeitlupe
es gibt keinen größeren unsinn eine
pandemie ist eine explosion dann ist ja
alles klar ist jetzt kein vorwurf
ausdrücklich kein vor wie sein neues
virus das heißt auch die wissenschaft
lernt ständig dazu so funktioniert
wissenschaft und so oder so virologen
sind dennoch unsere neuen popstars ihre
podcast gehen durch die decke und die
vermarktungsmaschine die ist gar nicht
mehr aufzuhalten
em 2020 abgesagt die fußball welt
trauert millionen panini alben sind nur
noch toilettenpapier matrix jetzt am
kiosk
unser pandemie album sammle die bilder
von deutschlands coolsten virologen zb
von alexander kekule
bei anne will plasberg oder meischberger
das panini sammelalbum mit allen
gesichtsausdrücken von rkw chef lothar
wieler mal besorgt mal mahnend mal
zurückhaltend optimistisch plus start
für fotos von christian drosten mit
besonders vollen lippen geil das panini
sammelalbum jetzt am kiosk
also ausgeschlossen dann nicht
ich glaube hat auf übrigens die
virologen können natürlich gar nichts
für den medienhype und richtig
durchatmen werden wir sowieso erst wenn
der impfstoff da ist oder bei so wenig
neuinfektionen dass man wieder einzelne
infektionsketten nachverfolgen kann
wer weiß vielleicht lernen wir sogar was
aus gewinner aus den pandemien davor
haben wir zwar erschreckend wenig
gelernt aber das liegt ja nur daran dass
wir doof sind herzlich willkommen zu
terror mix die dümmsten die hre der welt
mit christian ehring herzlich willkommen
zu den dümmsten tieren der welt liebe
zuschauer wer holt sich die krone für
mich ganz klar auf platz drei diese
katze voll auf die fresse was für eine
dumme katze auf der 2 samy der und er
versucht einen frisbee zu fangen jetzt
so ein vollidiot alle wirklich sehr dumm
aber ohne chance gegen das dümmste
lebewesen des planeten
der homo sapiens die gattung homo aus
der familie der menschenaffen ich bin
sehr stolz zu recht nur dieser affenart
steht für eine einmalig toxische melange
aus arroganz und todessehnsucht vor haas
schon wieder eine krankheit die von tier
auf mensch überspringt wie konnte das
denn passieren
die voraussetzungen dafür schaffen wir
menschen selbst indem wir viren aus
bisher isolierten lebensräumen wie
tropischen regenwäldern herausholen und
sie mit neuen wirten in kontakt bringen
so für noch mehr palmöl und soja fordert
zerstören wir ganze ökosysteme und
bringen viren mit völlig neuen wirken
zusammen wieso schmierige während
zuhälter und zur strafe wird ihm hier
die selbsternannte krone der schöpfung
hallo ironischerweise von winzigen mikro
organismen platt gemacht es war doch
seit sich jahren bekannt dass diese wild
hier merkte krank sind fischer
zusammengepfercht auf engstem raum
wälzen sich da in fremden körper
sekreten also im grunde wie wir am
ballermann ohne die show ist musik
märz jetzt kommt alles immer schneller
er hätte ja mal was klingeln eben da
hätte längst nur was klingeln müssen
andererseits ehring wer konnte ahnen
dass dieser bill gates in seinen laboren
tatsächlich so ein virus züchtet was
bill gates warnt seit jahren vor exakt
dem was wir gerade erleben hat keine sau
interessiert
man vermute dass in fledermäusen noch
mindestens 40 weitere coronaviren
schlummern verstehen sie nicht der
planet versucht uns loszuwerden
das möchte ich auch immer sehen
christian wie die tiere ohne uns klar
kommen soll sich die ferkel dem nicht
selber kastrieren oder was umgekehrt
wird ein schuh draus alles erholt sich
gerade die luft wird überall besser und
im zoo von hongkong haben die pandas
neuerdings wieder sex weil ihnen keine
blöden zoobesucher mehr zu gucken beim
homo sapiens steigt gegen korona die
scheidungsrate und die panthers haben
spaß ich hoffe da ist jetzt endlich mal
was hängen geblieben bei ihnen die
pandas angebot mein gott
christian engl
[Applaus]
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
eine last
ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen abo da